oh my god welcome to the cemetery
hahahaha it says it this is a co-op
style game I never played it before but
I'm pretty out called-- okay will you
have your brush crack in your head
that's terrible
hey everyone my name is bone face today
is Monday your calorie target yeah
skinny [ __ ] gotta watch them calories
you have 20 seconds left click to start
oh yeah yeah alright gotta have some
[ __ ] toast yes I what happened why
did I do wrong
there we go eat it eat it oh no the
ghost is the ghost took my toast yeah
damnit how do I do this getting that
sweet ass toast I'm hoping Gus mouth and
I'm eating it eat all those calories
oh no ghost s my toast no don't no you
cannot have my toast
delicious toast cinnamon toast can I
think whoa we got all them calories now
we can keep being a fabulous model as we
are of course today's Tuesday calorie
target is 250 oh well today's my chic
day apparently damn that's a lot ik all
right damn it
ha ha ha goddamnit a true
stop it egg god damn it oh it's coming
back to me come back to me egg I know
you want me
ah so close delicious nutritious and
freshest leaf dishes
awesome high fibrous pancakes I love
pancakes
alright ha ha [ __ ] up one went to space
well what can you do now my eye what
damn [ __ ] what happened now pancake you
is I now seriously this no oh well it's
tastier this way why is it so hard to be
skinny and cheek people don't realize
how about I just do like this [ __ ]
come here pancake this is how we eat in
Sweden
goddammit you're on get away these are
my pancakes
Kurian yeah I just wanted a hug Jaron
moon walks out ha ha ha ha escape
breakfast is happening get good for you
what do we got Skeletor is my favorite
that calcium is important for his
gallatin you grab our knife and then we
grab our table of course and then we eat
the tape and done thank you
seriously seriously get it ha ha ha just
pour it
that doesn't look weird at all that's
great and now we can fully enjoy our
breakfast numb at [ __ ] this table time
good job good day I don't take my table
good that's my camera god damn damn yo
Ganta cost you 2 Halligan's ah son of a
[ __ ] stole my breakfast table who does
that
eat it eat it no no oh god i'm eat up my
eye why do I keep doing it digested
dammit I'm blind
oh look I have boobs now even my boobs
leave me I'm so lonely what the [ __ ] the
table is stucking god damn it darshan
i'm at freddy hanne-liebe that all
really I hate you oh my god huh ok one
last [ __ ] try Brae it everywhere let
my name be known as as [ __ ] I'll eat
all the pockets Ariel
that's my new name change my new YouTube
channel what the [ __ ] happened with
table table whatever I told you by being
possessed oh my god it's a skeleton gang
in breakfast meal of the year all year
bacon and eggs the breakfast of a real
dead man
come here bacon don't fight me bacon
bacon
koonta good to stay the [ __ ] away from
my bacon that's what my fork what are
you gonna do with that gun jar freddy
he'll bet that off they leave a table oh
god Splott everywhere now this is not
how you eat bacon
I think eat it eat it eat it come on
bacon gets in my mouth when I say it
damn it bacon
gonta don't you dare take my table I
swear to god Kunta I swear to God my
hatred for Gunther gross
[ __ ] me in the ass good da I hate you
how can I not eat it it's in my mouth
that's why she they ha all everyone it
was to have bacon and no one's gonna
stop me
good day is gonna stop me damn you
Gunther grabbing [ __ ] come into my
mouth please please please ah ah eat it
eat it
nah I became a fountain come to Papa
that's right
good bacon good bacon you're supposed to
get in my mouth now you listen here
close bacon I had enough of you and your
tricks
Freddy Hellmuth at all what the [ __ ] is
going on there Mets top button it up and
on you will all go inside my mouth damn
it just eat the damn picking please oh
and your farted how [ __ ] marvelous
thank you you piece of [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
Yas Wow [ __ ] you Gunther what are you
gonna do Goethe let's try you better
moon walk away [ __ ] can we stop I mean
I'm done
alright you know what [ __ ] you alright
press I've tended there they would like
me to do watching I leave a link to this
game you want to get it and script in a
little bit that's all for me for now
sounds and birds love you bye
you